اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض وهذه ابرز وعناوين
اليوم
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يلتقي ولي العهد
السعودي في جده ويبحثان الملفات الاقليميه
والدوليه
نتائج انتخابات مجلس الامه الكويتي تكشف
عن عشره اسماء جديده امراه وحيده تصل لقبه
البرلمان
الملك سلمان يصدر امرا بانشاء مؤسسه منتدى
الامن السيبراني للاسهام في تعزيزه عالميا
ومن ملفات الرابعه ايضا
بعد التفاعل الواسع على منصات التواصل
العم سلطان يروي للعربيه قصه التبني وحفله
تخرج
الارصاد تؤكد عدم تاثير الحاله الجويه في
برجوي على اجواء السعوديه خلال لثنتين
وسبعين ساعه القادمه
حياكم الله اجتمع ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز مع
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي جدا واستعرض
الجانبان العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين
الصديقين كما استعرض اوجه التعاون في
مختلف المجالات وسبل تعزيزها الى جانب
تطورات الاوضاع الاقليميه والدوليه
والجهود المبذوله بشانه وكان وزير خارجيه
الامريكي انتوني قد وصل يوم امس جده لبحث
التعاون الاستراتيجيه الامريكي السعودي في
القضايا الاقليميه والعالميه هذا وتنطلق
اليوم في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض اعمال
الاجتماع الوزاري بين وزراء خارجيه دول
مجلس التعاون وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انتونيكن وذلك في اطار التعاون
الاستراتيجي الخليجي الامريكي وتعزيز
العلاقات الثنائيه بين دول المجلس واشنطن
ومن الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
نصفيان هاني مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض ما هي خلفيات
تفاصيل هذا الاجتماع
المختلف عن الاجتماعات الدوريه بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ودول مجلس
التعاون
نعم اهلا بك يا نايف واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه اذا كما تحدثت هو اجتماع مختلف
ليس اجتماعا دوريا او كذلك ثابتا انما هو
اجتماع من اجل شراكه جديده استراتيجيه او
شراكه استراتيجيه جديده بين دول المجلس
وكذلك امريكا اليوم ان توني بلينكين وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي سوف يكون في هذا
الاجتماع اذا سوف يكون اجتماع خليجي
امريكي بحضور وزراء خارجيه دول المجلس سوف
يناقشون الاستراتيجيه الجديده في تعزيز
التعاون في مجالات عده وملفات عده
اقتصاديه وسياسيه وكذلك امنيه وكذلك ايضا
متابعه ما هو يدور في الشان الاقليمي
وكذلك الدولي اليوم سوف يسبق هذا الاجتماع
الخليجي الامريكي اجتماعات ثنائيه بين بعض
وزراء خارجيه دول المجلس وكذلك وزير
الخارجيه
امريكي ولعل ما تم تاكيده واجتماع وزير
الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان مع
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني وسوف يكون
قبل بدء الاجتماع الخليجيه الامريكي او
الذي سوف يكون في تمام الساعه الخامسه
والنصف بتوقيت المحلي السعودي اي بعد ساعه
ونصف من الان الى تغير الامر وطالت
الاجتماعات الثنائيه بين البلينكن وكذلك
وزراء خارجيه دول المجلس عموما سبق ايضا
هذا هذه او سبق ايضا
بدء الاجتماعات وكذلك الاستعدادات لهذا
الاجتماع الخليجي الامريكي كان وصول بلينك
يوم امس الى مدينه جده والتقائه ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان والذي تحدث
مع ولي العهد فيما ملفات كثيره كما وصفها
بلينكن يوم امس في رده على احد الصحفيين
طبعا
وصل ايضا او غادر من جده ووصل الرياض وفي
هذه الاثناء وفي اللحظات القادمه سوف
يتبين ايضا الاجتماعات الثنائيه الاخرى
بين بلينكن وكذلك وزراء دول المجلس اضافه
الى اجتماعه المؤكد مع وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان واضح شكرا
جزيلا لك من الرياض انضم الينا مراسل
العربيه نصفيان شكرا جزيلا للنهائي
علاقه استراتيجيه تمتد لثمانيه عقود هكذا
لخصت الخارجيه الامريكيه في بيان لها
العلاقه بين الرياض واشنطن وذلك قبيله بدء
زياره بلينكن الى السعوديه وبحسب البيان
مشاهدينا تواصل الولايات المتحده شاركتها
مع السعوديه في عده قضايا منها القضايا
السياسيه والامنيه ومكافحه الارهاب
والاقتصاد ومن القضايا المشاركه ايضا بين
البلدين قضايا الطاقه النظيفه لتعزيز جهود
البلدين المشتركه في بناء شرق اوسط اكثر
امانا واستقرارا العمل على ضمان الامن
الاقليمي يعد احد اسس العلاقه بين البلدين
حسب بيان خارجيه الامريكيه والتي من شانها
ان تعزز امن الخليج والقدره على ردع اي
تهديد لامن المنطقه
وبحسب الخارجيه الامريكيه فان واشنطن عقدت
التزاما بتعزيز شراكه الامنيه مع الرياض
عبر دعم البنيه التالي الدفاعيه الجويه
والتدريبات المشتركه بين البلدين
[تصفيق]
وعند الحديث عن الازمات العالميه الحاليه
فان السعوديه والولايات المتحده تعملان
معا على حل ازمه السودان الحاليه وحمايه
المدنيين وتمكين وصول المساعدات في البلاد
كما تدعم السعوديه الجهود التي قامت بها
الامم المتحده في خفض التصعيد واحلال
السلام في اليمن ورحبت الولايات المتحده
مشاهدينا بالخطوات التي اتخذتها السعوديه
لدعم اوكرانيا بما في ذلك التعهد بتقديم
مساعدات بقيمه 400 مليون دولار يتحدث الان
مشاهدينا عن المشهد الاقتصادي بين البلدين
مع تنويع اقتصادها في اطار رؤيه 2030 تعمل
السعوديه على تطوير بدائل نظيفه للطاقه
التقليديه وهو ما اعتبره بيان الخارجيه
الامريكيه فرصا كبيره لشركات الامريكيه
ففي عام 2022 وقع البلدان شراكه ثنائيه
لتعزيز الطاقه النظيفه من اجل البنيه
التحتيه العالميه والاستثمار وهذا الامر
مشاهدينا سيعزز باستثمارات ويسهل تسريع
انتقال تحول الطاقه ومكافحه اثار تغير
المناخ وعند النظر الى المجال التعليمي
مشاهدينا بين السعوديه وامريكا فان لدى
البلدين علاقات ثقافيه وتعليميه عريقه
وممتده فكما نشاهد نشاهد هنا مشاهدينا
هناك اكثر من ثمانيه عشر الف طالب سعودي
يدرسون حاليا في الجامعات الامريكيه كما
تخرج نحو 700 الف من المؤسسات الامريكيه
على مدى العقود الخمسه الماضيه هذه
التبادلات التعليميه والمهنيه والثقافيه
وحتى الرياضيه منها بين الافراد تسهم وحسب
البيان الامريكي في تعزيز العلاقات بين
الرياض وواشنطن
من الرياض تنضم الينا المتحدثه الاقليميه
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه هاله غريط سيده
هلا مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض ما هي الدوافع وراء هذه الزياره
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
لقائه ايضا ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد
بن سلمان في هذا التوقيت
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه وانا فرحانه جدا
اكون معاكم من الرياض هذا الزياره من وزير
بلينكن تظهر اهميه العلاقات بين الولايات
المتحده ومملكه العربيه السعوديه كما
سمعنا العلاقات الثانويه بين البلدين يعني
تاريخيه استراتيجيه مهمه جدا اكثر من 80
سنه العلاقات عميقه وهذه هذه الزياره مهمه
بالنسبه للعلاقه الثانويه ولكن كذلك
الاقليميه والدوليه
تفضل
العلاقه كما ذكرتي ممتده لثمانيه عقود لكن
ربمانا مع هذه الاداره الامريكيه كما يرى
الكثير من المراقبين
بانها يعني مختلفه تتصاعد في احيان وتهبط
ربما في احيان الملفات التي تم نقاشها في
هذه ايضا حتى لو في هذا اللقاء وصفها
بانها ملفات كثيره لاحد الصحفيين فما هي
اولويات الخارجيه الامريكيه في هذه
الزياره وفي اللقاء الذي تم ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
تحت هذه الاداره العلاقات قويه جدا اكيد
هناك تحديات بين كل الحلفاء وكل شركاء
ولان نحن عندنا علاقه قويه مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ممكن نتحدث ونناقشوا على
كثير من الملفات منها
التحديات ولكن هذا لان العلاقه قويه بس
الوزير بلان كانت لما سمعنا كان امس في
الجده وكان عنده لقاء مع واهل عهد محمد بن
سلمان وناقشوا كثير من الملفات منها
السودان
ويعني العلاقات الثنائيه
لا اريد ارتبط كثير من من الوزير نفسه لان
هل سنسمعه غدا من من الوزير نفسه ولكن
الان كذلك هو هو الان في الرياض وصل هذا
اليوم في الرياض واستيقابل مع مع قيادات
نساء سعوديات هذا هذا شيء مهم جدا سيشارك
في مجلس التعاون الخليجي وسيلتقى مع كل
حلفاؤنا من المنطقه
وغدا كذلك سيشارك في تحالف الدولي لهزيمه
داعش مع اكثر من 30 وزراء من حول العالم
يعني هذا التحالف يشمل اكثر من 80 دوله
والولايات المتحده تشكر المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
لهذا الشراك في هذا التحالف ضد هذا الشيء
مهم جدا وكما نرى انه العلاقات الثانويه
يعني مهمه جدا في كثير من الملفات كما
ذكرنا طيب يعني قبل قليل زميلها نسفين كان
موجود في مقر الاجتماعات مجلس التعاون
الخليج وزراء الخارجيه مع الوزير بلنكن
بانه اجتماع غير دوري
واهميه هذا الاجتماع بان هناك
استراتيجيات جديده ستكون في شكل هذه
العلاقه الخليجيه الامريكيه
هل من ملامح لهذه الاستراتيجيه
لا يمكنني استبك اي قرار من من النقاش
ولكن ممكن اقول انه بدون اي شك انه
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بمجلس التعاون
الخليجي بكل شركائنا في الخليج بما في ذلك
اكيد المملكه العربيه السعوديه والوزير
لكن هنا ممكن يتحدث مباشره مع نذريه
السعودي وكل الوزراء من من
المنطقه ولكن لا يمكنني قرار منها ولكن
بالتاكيد سيناقشك كل الملفات يعني في
المنطقه وخارج يعني مثل روسيا واوكرانيا
وكل القضايا المهمه بالنسبه للمنطقه شكر
جزيل من الرياضه انضمت الينا المتحدثه
الاقليميه باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه شكرا
جزيلا
والى الكويت حيث صدر امر اميري بقبول
استقاله الحكومه وتكليفها بتصريف الاعمال
هذا وتشهد البلاد في العشرين من الشهر
الجاري بدا اعمال الفصل التشريعي السابع
عشر لمجلس الامه والذي اعلنت
نتائج والذي اعلنت نتائج اعضائه الخمسين
يوم امس وشهدت فوزي عشره اسماء جديده
بالاضافه لاربعين من اعضاء سابقين في
المجلس كما حملت نتائج الانتخابات
البرلمانيه الاخيره فوز الرئيسين السابقين
مرزوق الغانم واحمد السعدون كما شهدت
الانتخابات فوز امراه واحده من بين ثلاثه
عشره مرشحه اخرى
من الكويت تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه
شهد المتروك شاهد مرحبا بك معي في نشاط
الرابعه من الرياض انتهت النتائج اعلنت
بشكل كامل ما هو الملفت في نتائج انتخابات
هذا العام 2023 للبرلمانيه في الكويت
نعم نايف يعني اليوم رسميا اعلنت نتائج
انتخابات مجلس الامه 2023 وبالتالي اعلنت
ايضا اسماء الفائزين
بمقعد في البرلمان الكويتي طبعا من كل
دائره من الدوائر الخمس يوجد عشر مرشحين
فازوا بمقعد في
مجلس الامه الكويتيه طبعا الملفت هو تفاوت
عدد الناخبين في كل دائره وبالتالي
الاصوات التي حصل عليها
النواب الجدد في كل دائره بناء على
عدد الناخبين في هذه الدوائر وعدد الذين
ادلوا باصواتهم قد تتراوح ما بين 65 لبعض
النواب الجدد بينما النواف الدوائر الاخرى
يعني حصلوا على فوق ال 10,000 و12 الف حتى
وصلت عدد الاصوات التي حصلوا عليها بسبب
ارتفاع عدد الناخبين في تلك الدوائر مثلا
الدائره الخامسه يصل عدد الناخبين فيها او
اكثر من
الف ناخب وناخبه بينما مثلا في الدائره
الثالثه عدد الناخبين والناخبات
الاجمالي يصل تقريبا الى اكثر من 90 الف
ناخب وناخبه طبعا هناك اعتراض طبعا من بعض
المواطنين من بعض المحللين على ترتيب
تقسيم هذه الدوائر والمناطق التي تنتمي
الى الدوائر الخمس تحقيق الارقام اذا
حسبناها بالنسبه تقريبا متقاربه لدينا
ابرز الاسماء التي نجحت في هذه الانتخابات
رغم الاصوات التي حصلت عليها مثلا رئيس
مجلس الامه
المركز الاول في دائره الثانيه 6600 او
اكثر من 6600 صوت بينما مثلا في الدائره
الثالثه رئيس مجلس الامه السابق ايضا احمد
السعدون حصل على المركز الثاني باصوات
تتجاوز 6300 صوت لكن في الانتخابات
السابقه حصل مثلا على اكثر من 12,000
الصوت هناك تفاوت يعني حتى
رغبتهم بانتخاب مرشح مختلف هذا العام يعني
هذا السؤال عن الناخب اليوم وشو يتوقع من
المجلس المزاج للناخب الكويتي ايضا كيف
اختلف في هذه الانتخابات طبقا للنتائج
يعني نسبه الاقبال هل كانت اقل منخفضه
بكثير عن نسبه الاقبال في العمل الماضي
بانتخابات العام الماضي
يعني حسب نسبه الاقبال التي تجاوزت
الخمسين بالمئه بقليل عن الانتخابات
الماضيه بسبب قرب يعني وقت الانتخابات
الماضيه التي لم تكمل سته اشهر مع هذه
الانتخابات كان هناك نوع من الاحباط الذي
يسود الاجواء اجواء الانتخابات لكن بنفس
الوقت يعني عندما عملنا استطلاع رايي قبل
قليل وسالنا المواطنين عن ماذا يتعاملون
من المجلس القادم وبرايهم
بالانتخابات او النتائج الانتخابات هذه
ممن الذي صوت يعني غل نتامل خير وبالعكس
مرشحين هم الذين صوتوا لهم فازوا بمقعد في
البرلمان لكن الذي لم يصوت قال بان نفس
الوجوه عاده صوت ام لم اصوت نفس الوجوه
عاده ربما نفس
المشاهد او سيناريوهات التي كانت في
المجالس السابقه قد تتكرر في هذا المجلس
سنسال عن هذا التكرر اذا من الكويت مراسله
العربيه شهاده ماتروك شكرا جزيلا لك
والله شوف النتائج
على شوف الزينه اذا صار في تفاهم بين
المجلس والحكومه والله ان شاء الله توقع
عند رب العالمين للحين ما بدا عند رب
العالمين بس الشباب اللي يطلعوا
وجوه جديده يعني وجود جديده وان شاء الله
فيهم خير نتامل انه المجلس ينجز بما في
مصلحه البلد وشعب والله نتائج اتمنى لهم
كل خير واللي نجحوا الله يوفقهم واللي ما
نجحوا المره الجايه ان شاء الله راح
ينجحون ان شاء الله باذن الله والله
تكون هي زينه لان صار في تغيير بالنسبه
زينه عشان يصير يتوافق بين الحكومه
والمجلس على اساس امور قوانين وصالح البلد
تمشي بشكل زين لان الكويت ينضم الينا
الباحث في نتائج انتخابات مجلس الامه صلاح
الجاسم سيد صلاح حياك الله معي في نشاه
الرابعه من الرياض وخليني ابدا معك مم
انتهت به زميلاتنا شاهد المتروك قبل قليل
عن تكرار
الوجوه في هذه النتائج عطفا على هذه
النتائج للانتخابات اليوم هل تتوقع بان
الكويت ستشهد عهدا جديدا مختلفا بمجلسه
على مجلس السابق عن ايضا حتى ربما الحكومه
ام تكرار الوج وه سيعيدنا الى نفس المربع
الاول
بعضا في عوده لنفس يعني ايه هي في مساله
رئيسيه عندنا ومساله رئيسيه اللي هي
محاوله سيطره فريق او انه فريق يغلب فريق
هذه المساله لو تنازل احد الفريقين عنها
تمشي الامور لكن اللي حاصل هذا يبي غالب
هذا وهذا يبي يغلب هذا وماشيه الامور على
كذا ان شاء الله يعني في سمعنا بوادر بان
الاثنين عندهم الرغبه
يكون هناك استقرار وهناك انجاز خصوصا بعد
اللي سمعناه من الاخ مرزوق الغانم
بانه في رغبه بالاستقرار ونتامل يعني ما
امامنا الا نتامل وان شاء الله خير يعني
نسبه المشاركين في هذه الانتخابات لم
تتجاوز 50 في المئه على سبيل المثال مثلا
يعني احمد السعدون في الانتخابات السابقه
حصل على اكثر من 12 الف صوت في هذه
الانتخابات تقريبا
6000 وكسور هل هذا يعود لانه في عزوف عن
الاقتراع امم يعني خلينا نقول لنتائج عمل
احمد السعودي ربما في المجلس السابق ما
حدث في المجلس السابق فبالتالي اثرت عليه
في الانتخابات انا اقتصم كان نموذج
ما نقدر نقيس على انه فلان حصل على كذا
وبالتالي في عزوف العزوف يقاس على اجمالي
اللي حاضرين في عزوف
نتيجه عوامل عديده منها الحر ومنها توقيت
السفر ومنها التمل من التكرار السيناريو
يعني
فنعمل ان هذا العزوف يعني ما يستمر في
الانتخابات القادمه ولكن احمد السعدون عدم
حصوله على رقم كبير
نتيجه ظروف لكل انتخابات ظروفها
الالتهابات السابقه لها ظروفها وهذا
الانتخابات لها ظروفها ما تقدر تقيس كل
الانتخابات على نفس
لا ممكن يعني مثلا شعيب
الاول وصار العاشر فهذا ما يعني ان في
عزوف ما لها علاقه المساله
هذا السؤال وبالفعل الفعل
اللي قاعدين ناخذه من الجرائد
وعلى مدى 60 سنه الماضيه ما في نشر رسمي
للنتائج لكن نعمل ان تكون هذه السنه
استثناء ويتم نشر نتائج الانتخابات حتى
نقدر نجاوب اسئله مثل اللي طرحتها حضرتك
اليوم تركيبه النواب حسب النتائج اللي
صارت برايك تصب في مصلحه من هل تصب في
مصلحه مرزوق الغانم ام تصب في مصلحه احمد
السعدون لنتوقع من هو رئيس البرلمان
القادم
تقصد الرئاسه الرئاسه ما يعني غالبا
محسومه
احمد السعدون ولا اظن مرزوق يعني ما ادري
عنه اذا بترشح او لا لكن الوضع ما اظن في
صالحه اذا ترشح هذا فيما يتعلق بالرئاسه
لكن
الاهم من منو يصير رئيس الاهم هل راح
يستمر الصراع ولا الامور تركد هل راح
يلتفتون كلهم
لمصلحه الدوله ولا كل واحد يبي يغلب
الثاني
يعادل النقطه الرئيسيه اللي صار لنا من
2012 للحين فيها على عمل انه ينصلح الحال
هالمجلس هذا اخيرا يمكن في نقطه على على
بعض النواب الذين سقطوا مثلا يعني مخضر
مثلا مثل صالح عاشور يمكن انت اتيت على
ذكرى قبل قليل
وسقط فيها الانتخابات ونجح نائب مثلا مثل
داود معرفه هو المره الثانيه اعتقد اللي
يدخل او يخوض فيها
الانتخابات وش تفسيرها برايك
بالنسبه لصالح عاشور سقوط
متعمد مو منا هو طبعا
في يعني في بعض الترتيبات
نتيجتها نزل واحد من نفس الفئه
والامر طبيعي انه يسخط وفي ناس ثانيه بعد
صارت معاهم نفس الترتيبات ناس قدرت على
هذه الترتيبات ونجحت ناس ما قدرت
[موسيقى]
مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بريطانيا تغير من سياستها في اصدار
تاشيرات دخول الخليجيين ومواطني الاردن
حياكم الله من جديد اصدر للملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز امرا ملكيا بانشاء مؤسسه
المنتدى الدولي للامن السيبراني لتكون
مؤسسه
ذات شخصيه اعتباريه وتتمتع بالاستقلال
المالي والاداري وغير هادفه الى الربح كما
تتمتع المؤسسه بالاهليه الكامله لتحقيق
اهدافها واداره شؤونها تحت اشراف مجلس
امناء خاص بها ويكون مقرها الرئيس في
مدينه الرياض هذا وتهدف المؤسسه الى
الاسهام في تعزيز الامن السيبراني على
المستوى الدولي
تبدا المدارس في السعوديه اضافه بعض
المناهج الجديده في الخطه التعليميه
للطلاب والطالبات هذا وستتم اضافته مناهج
علوم الارض والفضاء ومبادئ القانون وهندسه
البرمجيات والامن السيبراني بالاضافه الى
الذكاء الاصطناعي في الخطه الدراسيه وكانت
الخطط الدراسيه لوزاره التعليم قد شهدت
تغييرا وتحديدا خلال السنوات الماضيه شمل
التعديل محتوى بعض المواد بالاضافه ايضا
الى اضافه مواد جديده
ودمج مواد اخرى ايضا
من الرياض ينضموا لنا المشرف العام على
البرنامج التنفيذي لتطوير المسارات والخطط
الدراسيه والاكاديميات بوزاره التعليم
الدكتور ابراهيم الحميدان الدكتور ابراهيم
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
وخلينا نسال عن هذا التغير اليوم اضافه
بعض المناهج الجديده الى المدارس في
السعوديه ابرز هذه المناهج التي تم
اضافتها
اولا مساكم الله بالخير وتحياتي لكل زملاء
المستمعين والمشاهدين حياك الله دكتور
فيما يخص النقل النوعيه التي تحدث في
وزاره التعليم وامتداد لمرحله امتدت لعده
سنوات في قضيه اضافه جديده تتسق مع مهاره
القانون الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه وعصر
المعرفه كثير من المواد اصبحت ضروره مطلب
خصوصا مع توجهات الدوله نحو
التعامل مع انكشاف المهني والوظائف الحرجه
ومتطلبات سوق العمل لابد ان تتحرك وزاره
التعليم بهذا الاتجاه لذا كانت سباقه في
هذا الامر استبقت في كثير من الاحداث كما
ذكرنا
قبل عده ايام فيما
يخصها تقريبا من سنتين هذه الماده ايضا
المواد الجديده للتعلق الامن السيبراني
والذكاء الاصطناعي وايضا ما يخص الدعم
كاداره الفعاليات واداره الاعمال
كل هذه المواد تستجيب لمتطلبات المرحله
وداعمه لرؤيه 203 في قضيه حل مشكله
التوظيف وصوره انتقال الطلاب وتعلمهم
المهارات جدا مطلوبه في سوق العمل طيب
دكتور يعني انا بقول لك بعض هذه المواد
يعني اللي موجوده اذا كانت صحيحه ولا لا
علوم الارض والفضاء الرعايه الصحيه انظمه
الجسم مبادئ القانون اداره الفعاليات
تخطيط الحملات التسويقيه الذكاء الاصطناعي
وهندسه البرمجيات والامن السيبراني هل هذه
كل المواد اللي تحضيها
كمان مواد مواد اخرى مثل المعرف
ه الرقيه والمقاميه والتفكير الناقد
ومهارات البحث
والفنون في المرحله الثانويه ولا يقل
الثقافه الصحيح كل هذه المواد الوظيفيه
عمليه اضيفت ايضا الدكتور حتكون الزاميه
او اجباريه للطلاب طبعا في في مسارات
المرحله الثانويه هنالك مواد اختياريه
هناك مواد اساسيه هناك مواد السنه الاولى
مشتركه ايضا المواد الزمنيه على حسب
المسارات التخصصيه في مواد خاصه مسار
والهندسه في مواد خاصه في الصحه والحياه
في مواد خاصه في اداره الاعمال في مواد
خاصه المسار الشرعي في مواد في المسار
العامه طيب في مواد مثلا مثل العلوم الارض
والفضاء او مثل الامن السيبراني ايضا حتى
كذلك او ذكاء حتى الاصطناعي السؤال عن في
كميه معلمين او مؤهلين ايضا كذلك قادرين
على تدريس هذه المواد لديكم دكتور
حركت وزاره التعليم في ثلاثه اتجاهات
الاتجاه الاولى الاول كان في توظيف مباشر
العام الماضي عشره الاف
متوقعه ايضا الرقم يمكن ضعف الرقم هذا في
هذا التخصصات النوعيه اضف الى ذلك لدينا
برنامج الاستثمار الامثل يستمد الفصل
الدراسي او سنه دراسيه كامله
لتحسين مستوى المعلمين بالذات علوم الحاسب
ايضا
البرامج المباشره التدريب المركزي
للمعلمين تقريبا اكثر من 90 برنامج مواجهه
المعلمين في المرحله الثانويه يعني سيكون
هناك توظيف لعشرين الف معلم هذا العام
دكتور
انا لا اصرح في هذا الرقم لكن التوجهات ان
شاء الله يكون فيها توظيف جيد ويقدم توجات
الجديده في الوزاره
طيب ممتاز اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات على المشاركه معي والمشرف العام
على البرنامج التنفيذي لتطوير المسارات
والخطط الدراسيه والاكاديميات لوزاره
التعليم الدكتور ابراهيم الحميدان
اعلنت المملكه المتحده في بيان لها عن بدء
اجراء تصريح السفر الالكتروني الجديد
للزوار القادمين من مجلس التعاون الخليجي
والاردن بتكلفه تبلغ 10 جنيهات استرلينيه
لكل متقدم وجاء في البيان ان التاشيره
ستكون جاريه لمده عامين من تاريخ اصدارها
وان الاجراء الجديد سيكون محلا نظام فيزا
ويفر الحالي ما يجعل عمليه
السفر الى بريطانيا اسهل واسرع واشاره
البيان ايضا الى ان الاجراء الجديد يزيل
متطلبات التاشيره لمواطني السعوديه وقطر
وعمان والكويت والامارات والبحرين والاردن
الذين يرغبون في زياره المملكه المتحده
مقاطع فيديو نشرها حساب البرنامج الوطني
لمكافحه التستر في السعوديه عن حيل عديده
يقوم بها مخالفين للانظمه او يقوم بها
مخالفون للانظمه وممارسون للتستر التجاري
من بينها مدخل مخفي لاحدى الشقق عبر ثلاجه
منزليه نتابع
[موسيقى]
كشفت جمعيه تعافي في السعوديه والمختصه
بتاهيل الراغبين بالتعافي من المخدرات
كشفت عن ارتفاع نسبه الاستشارات المتعلقه
بالتعافي الى 500 في المئه خلال الشهرين
الماضيين التفاصيل مع زميل عبد الرحمن
العصيمي
وهؤلاء الشباب اخر عهدهم بالادمان في
اروقه جمعيه تعافي التي تقدم لهم برنامجا
نوعيا للتعافي من ادمان المخدرات هذه
الجمعيه هي الوحيده في السعوديه التي تقدم
هذا البرنامج حيث تستمر مدته 12 شهرا
ويتمحور حول زياده الاستبصار بالمرض
وتنشيط الدافعي للاستمرار بالتعافين
بالاضافه الى الوقايه من الانتكاسه عبر
اكتساب الكثير من المهارات واخيرا التمكين
والدمج المجتمعي
حاليا متواجدين في السكن التاهيلي التابعه
الخيريه وهو احد المشاريع الرئيسيه في
جمعيه تعافي اللي هي الخدمات التاهيليه
للمتعافين من المخدرات المؤثرات العقليه
ويرتكز هذا المشروع في الهدف الثالث
لجمعيه التعافي هو ما بعد العلاج ما بعد
ازاله السميه في المصحات التي تشرف على
وزاره الصحه ينتقل الينا المريض برغبه منه
ويتم استقباله وعمل التقييم المبداى له
وقبوله في البرنامج جمعيه تعافي تستقبل
الراغبين في العلاج من الادمان من داخل
السعوديه ودول الخليج العربي ايضا
[موسيقى]
عرض عليهم
اوقات اختبارات تقريبا
غرض علي ماده
نستخدم هنا بدايه الادمان تدري
يعني
الحكم النيه مع العائله في البيت
فما قدرت اتعاطى بسجون يعني بشكل
غيرت الحشيش
للاخواننا لا زالوا يعلمون من التعاطي
يتوجه للمراكز هذه والله بالعكس يعني
لقينا المحبه ولقينا ما المحبه صحيح يعني
بعد ما خلصت الثانويه بدات يعني اروح ويا
اصدقاء يعني الله يصلحهم
شفتهم يسووا هذه الحاجات فجاني فضول اني
اجرب اعيش الجو اللي هم عايشينه
بديت في هذا المشوار تقريبا ثمان سنوات
وكنت يعني في حاله يعني
من التعاطي وكذا
فاكلت حبوب وبعد الحبوب يعني تعطيت فوقه
فطحت وفردوس جرعه زائده
عندي اثنين اصحابي يفكروني اني نايم واحد
يقول نشيل عمر بنخليه بسيارته ونمشي
والثاني يقول لا ناخذ عمر المستشفى اللي
قال باخذ المستشفى شغلني وحطني في سيارتي
وشالني بالسياره الى المستشفى دخلني
في المستشفى تقريبا سبعه ايام غيبوبه وبعد
الغيبوبه وانتبهت وانا اغسل كذا فصار عندي
قصور كذا والحين عندي قصور كل المرحله
الرابعه يعني بين فتره وفتره اغسل
عندي ضغط وعندي سكر كله
ارتفاع كبير في نسب الاستشارات المتعلقه
بمكافحه المخدرات والتعافي منها جمعيه
تعافي في المنطقه الشرقيه وصلت النسبه
لديهم الى 500 في المئه تزامنا مع الحمله
الامنيه التي تقوم بها الداخليه السعوديه
هذه الايام عبد الرحمن العصيمي من الدمام
العربيه
[موسيقى]
كشف نائب الرئيس والمديره لداريف الشرق
الاوسط في شركه لوسيد موتورز فيصل السلطان
لموقع ارقام بان شركه بدات تسليم السيارات
الكهربائيه خلال الفتره الحاليه لعملاء
التجزئه واضاف سلطان ان سياره الكهربائيه
من الطلب وهناك الالاف من الحجوزات وسيتم
تسليم مئات الطلبات في الاشهر المقبله
متوقعا ان يكون هناك الكثير من السيارات
الكهربائيه في شوارع السعوديه وبخصوص
اسعار السياره قال انها تبدا من 440 الف
ريال شامله ضريبه القيمه المضافه للطراز
الاساسي
رابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
البريطانيه تفتح ابوابها في العاصمه
الرياض ضمن برنامج استقطاب المدارس
العالميه
حياكم الله من جديد بعد ان لاقت صورتهما
تفاعلا واسعا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
روى للعربيه المواطن السعودي سلطان
القحطاني قصه صورته مع سميره وحكايه تبنيه
لها حين كان موظفا في احد مستشفيات منطقه
عسير جنوب السعوديه نتابع
في الحقيقه انا كنت اشتغل في مستشفى
مسارات عبيده كنت اعمل رئيس الاقسام
الداخليه والتمريض
وكان من مهام عملي انه اتابع حالات
الاطفال
الظروف الخاصه يجون اطفال والناس تحولهم
على دار الرعايه وناس نسلم
الا بنتي سميره اراد الله لنا ولها هذا
تعثر تحويلها لاكثر من تسعه اشهر كبرت
وصار عمرها تسعه شهور في صرت اجي في
الصباح احضر بدري واخذها وانزلها على
الحدائق ثم رجعها بعد ما رجعها تبدا تصرخ
واقوى كذا يعني احيانا اتمنى اني ما
خرجتها
[موسيقى]
لعل ذلك سبحان الله كان السبب في اني
اخذها فطلبت احتضانها وبفضل الله كانت
لنا في احضاننا
احسن ما جانا في حياتنا دخلت المدرسه
خلصت مرحله الثانوي دخلت الجامعه طبعا حفل
التخرج هذا حكايه اخرى بالنسبه
لحياتنا معها كانت
تشاور لنا بايديها واحنا نشاور لها العصا
حقتي هذه
دخلني شعور غريب جدا جدا جدا اثناء
المسيره
ان لو كانت لوحدها ما عندها ام ولا اب ولا
اسر حاضنه كيف بيكون قلبها وخاطرها مكسور
امام زميلاتها اللي يشاوروا لاهلهم
وياشرون لهم وهي حاطه وناظره
حاطه نظرها في الارض ما عندها لا ام
والله كل ما اذكر هذا الموقف او هذا الوضع
واتخيله احس بحزن شديد جدا جدا جدا انا
نزلت الى اسفل
المدرجات علشان اشوفها من قريب
[موسيقى]
وانرت دخلت تحت الدرجه
على نفسي
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله رب العالمين تخرجت سميره
وانبسطنا معها وانبسطت وحنا الحمد لله
نشكر الله الذي لا اله الا هو قبل كل شيء
ثم اشكر عائلتي والله ان فيها سعاده لا
يعلمها الا الله في هذا الاحتضاء
يعني وانا صغيره امر بالعمر وعشت معاهم
وكبرت
وابدا ما حسيت ان في فرق بيني وبينهم لحد
الان ما في اي فرق واحس ان هذه انها يعني
مو قصتي وما قصر والله يجزاهم عني خير
الجزاء يعني هم لو مو موجودين يعني ما
اكتملت فرحتي يعني هم اللي يكملوا الفرحه
الا حستوني اني صدقت تخرجت
حبيبه قلبي
[موسيقى]
وعدوا موسم الامطار في الدول العربيه هو
الاطول في العالم حيث يمتد لتسعه اشهر
لكنه شحيح المطر التفاصيل في تقويم مع
خالد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
للامطار مواسم شتويه وصيفيه وخريفيه
الشتويه تبدا مع دخول موسم سهيل في اواخر
اغسطس لا دخل سهيل لا تامن
والصيفيه تبدا مع دخول موسم العقارب في
شهر مارس لادخلت العقارب ترى الخير قارب
وتنتهي مع دخول موسم اتوابع في شهر يونيو
اتويبع راعي بروج المخايل وما اذكر وادي
سايل ومع نهايه الامطار الصيفيه تبدا
الامطار الخريفيه على جنوب السعوديه
واليمن وسلطنه عمان وسميت بالخريفيه لانها
تتزامن مع موسم خراف الثمار فالسماء تمطر
عندهم وحنا بعز القير ولسان حالهم يقول
ولنا مطر المقيض بشهر اب وتموز وانتم
مجذبون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واطول موسم امطار بالعالم يكون على الدول
العربيه يمتى التقريبا لتسعه شهور لكنه
شحيح المطر وقبل الاف السنين كانت المده
اقصر سته شهور تقريبا لكن مطرها اغزر
واثرها اوضحوا على الارض بالانبات يفنى
العباد ولا تفنى صناعهم فاختر لنفسك ما
يحلو به الاثر
[موسيقى]
كتاب رابع بابرز عناوينها
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يلتقي ولي العهد
السعودي في جده ويبحثان الملفات الاقليميه
والدوليه
نتائج انتخابات مجلس الامه الكويتي تكشف
عن عشره اسماء جديده امراه وحيده تصل لقبه
البرلمان
الملك سلمان يصدر امرا بانشاء مؤسسه منتدى
الامن السيبراني للاسهام في تعزيزه عالميا
التفاعل الواسع على منصات التواصل العم
سلطان الروي للعربيه قصه التبني وحفل
التخرج
شكرا لكم والى
اللقاء لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات